you
can we can we took how you work with
directors cuz Oliver Stone bertolucci
Gus Renzi really Scott they're all very
different temperaments and and have
different styles here they sit in the
editing suite with you can't you just
talk about that process directors are
different I mean worked for many years
with Oliver Stone and he did not like
you know sitting in the cutting room
because it was just too slow you know it
was like watching paint rack no working
on on the film but he would come you
know later on in review and he would
actually be very specific about notes
and change it and even though a lot of
times we had things that would work he
said how can we make it better it was
really really pushing to make the best
we could and was really about quality
and the ultimate the best thing that we
can can achieve I my next experience
with Bertolucci was completely opposite
to that I mean also the environment in
the cutting was different
Oliver was very high strong I mean
always in combat mode you know kill him
kill him give it whatever it is whereas
we that with mr. Lucci was just the
total opposite environment very calm
very very generous also as an artist in
terms of the work and he liked spending
time in the cutting room working
together but it wasn't about hey no
let's cut this and let's look at some
other shots in this of this Bernardo
would tell stories tell stories about
you know puzzle Lena you're good are so
it was just great it was great hearing
that but the same time he would be able
to to focus on the work at hand in front
of it and I find very very close
similarities with Gus Van Sant and when
I worked with him we were working in
Gus's house in Portland in his living
room and Gus basically living like yeah
like a college student you know with
boxes yeah
I liked working in his house I would
cook lunch sometimes but he would be in
the cutting room playing his guitar but
they'll still focus you're just building
along and but I saw similarities to
Bertolucci because he was very much
influenced by
they told me that some of his favorite
films are you know the conformist and
Luna but he said he I studied those film
to family fare makers I studied was our
Kubrick and Bertolucci and I could see
from the camera movement from that the
way his cinematic language works that it
is about designing the scene based on
camera movements storytelling through
camera movement so there was a
familiarity and also the fact that he
loved editing and being in in the room
Sam Raimi would be in and out he liked
it as well with with Ridley Scott we are
very intensive editing after a while we
should but also after we have doing the
director's cut is we spend a lot of time
together and then basically leaves me to
finish it up when it comes down to you
know finishing visual effects of music
so he's half enough whenever his
schedule as it comes in but I know that
after the prints of father we really
spent a lot of time putting the movie in
shape